athletes do many um many of the same
things when they retire grank and his
former teammate Julian Edelman recently
had some fun with that so let's see it
we're retired athletes we're going to
get jobs on TV we're retired athletes
we're going to tease a comeback we're
retired athletes we're going to watch
our old highlights we're retired
athletes we're going to start a
podcast this should have been an SNL ski
it's so funny they should do that with
musicians as well we're retired athletes
you go on the Kelly Clarkson show good
time time so wait whose idea was that
are you into social media uh a little
bit okay yeah social media is cool you
know you got to use it for the right
reasons but I was at Julian edelman's
house he has a great podcast called
names with games yeah and uh we just did
his podcast and he has his whole social
media team there and then they showed me
this new trend on Tik Tok and that was
the new trend and they were like we're
going to do it as retired athletes and
it was such a great idea and it came out
so good I know I was telling him the
break I was like that should have been
on SNL that would have been a really
funny skit yeah so you have a new
partner for big game parties who is it
yes I actually do and Julian Edelman is
now a part of it as well and this is my
second year teaming up with Bounty and
that's why I'm in my green suit because
I am the Bounty man yeah and green is a
great color and I'm I'm from Buffalo so
I know a thing or two about Buffalo you
know wings as well and you got to always
have blue cheese on the side when you're
from Buffalo and you can't have football
without wings and you can't have wings
without Bounty okay I can't it gets
saucy messy the quicker pick up just com
clean you right up quicker picker uper I
remember that no I I agree with all of
that except um not the blue cheese I
have to have
Ranch and you're from Buffalo when
you're from Buffalo you use blue cheese
only when you're Texan you put Rancher
ketchup on everything but when you're
from Buffalo you got to have the buffalo
blue cheese but if you're outside of
Buffalo okay I won't make the argument
yes you can have
the buffalo blue cheese is the only
legit cheese I like blue cheese but
there's something about Ranch that I
really left no blue cheese really I the
ranch and I just want to I need
something The Vessel for it to wait till
you have the buffalo blue cheese okay I
have had I have had Buffalo I like it I
like it and maybe when I'm in Buffalo
I'll do that yes when you're in Buffalo
everywhere else I say
[Music]
no
[Applause]
thank you guys y have a great night I'm
going
home